leute willkommen zum ersten teil von uns
auf nachfragen von euch werden wir
darüber sprechen wie wir uns
kennengelernt haben generell zum talk es
geht halt werden über bestimmte themen
leben die uns vorgegeben zu vorschlag
sei es bei facebook twitter tumblr
instagram youtube
wir haben es auch bei facebook gefragt
was ihr so denkt was war was wir gut
reden könnten
da kam dann alles an über schwul oder
lesbisch über meteoriten über meine
haare
wie wir uns kennengelernt haben und erst
mal noch ganz kurz zum talk also das
wird jetzt nicht so höchst
professionelles es kann aber sein dass
wir einfach mal uns total viel mühe
gehen mit einem tollen als planen wenn
es um ein komplexes thema komplexeres
thema geht jetzt das ist ja einfach nur
da hinter den geschichten gelernt was
wir darüber reden muss ich daran meine
erste nachricht an dich denken sms
geschrieben habe damals auch fms ergab
sich dann doch der gab schon da hatte
ich gern prozent ich habe mir den den
chartverlauf mein iphone ist ein
bisschen gesplittet ich habe extra
gemacht dass man absolut okay ich kann
ja am ende einfach mal den wir gehen am
ende einfach mal den lauf so ein
bisschen durch den verlauf von dem
kompletten links ist ihr seht ihr das
ist ein bisschen spam nachricht einfach
nur drin wie curse und witzige sachen
dabei sache ist allerdings die dass ich
das einfach ans ende park und ein paar
witzige sachen einfach aussteigen und
dann seht ihr das halt so am ende und
jetzt quatsch exklusive uns überhaupt
keinen wert von normalen also aus
verschiedenen städten dörfern aus
hettstedt man gewohnt wird das ist schon
da sind wir in eine stufe gekommen naja
bekannten und konnten uns nicht boots
war das halt damals so es gab die a die
bbc und ideen also das war von einer
fünften sollen am ende am anfang hab
sondern auch die er aber die ehe wurde
dann aufgelöst als waren so richtig
bewusst halt einfach nicht mehr da war
wo ist dann habt ihr einfach aufgeteilt
die begleiter 56789
mehr zusammen sind wir jetzt nicht
zusammen
die klassen auf jeden fall erst ab der
oberstufe die sache war dann allerdings
die das dann in der ef also in der
zehnten klasse wurden wir alle vereint
da muss ich gedacht die machen sich
einfach ganz einfach packen uns alle
zusammen eine große klasse das war das
eine riesige stufe und dann als das haus
stapel alles sofort kaufen dann läuft
das nein also wir wurden alle zusammen
eine stufe gepackt hat verschiedene
kurse und
wir hatten ein glattes wahrheit so wir
hatten dafür elf kurse hat immer analoge
412 zusammen
zwei stunden hat mir alles ändern wir
alle zusammen dass der stephanstag der
suppe geschnuppert
nach diesem motto klar ganz gut klar
glaub ich in der woche sind wir wieder
kürzen becker regal haben jeden tag zehn
euro ausgekleidet euro jede woche zehn
euro ausgegeben übertreibt es überall
beachtet die kommentare gibt nachher
google ich dass er sich oder es gibt es
nicht überall
dann kommt gibt's überall durch
großeinkauf getätigt ich hab die chips
gekauft um diese koalabär gekocht hat
monster energy gekauft und damit auch
berlin konnte xing ag verfügte die
gekauft da hab ich dann insgesamt durch
mit einer falschen also neuen euro
ausgegeben wir haben einfach richtig
ungesund gelebt
immer schon und brötchen und capri sonne
das war auch die zeit war einfach das
war einfach alles richtig geil wieder
bisher musste nichts machen nef dass ich
das nächste leben denkbaren haben wir
angefangen
für beendet
das noch lücken das war irgendwie hatten
dann drei stunden miteinander
weil sport wir hatten immer donnerstags
ausgleich hatten wir dritte vierte frei
und fünfte war sportlich vierte fünfte
frei und sechs was sport genauso was
versprochen noch im falle da sind wir
dann einfach zu mir gefahren einer mine
macassa war der halt auch noch bei mir
sondern tiefer gespielt dann hat luca
seinen meister gefunden das hat sich
halt alles so aufgebaut wir waren halt
erst zusammen in einem kurs den wir auf
einer mehreren kursen zusammen dass wir
nebeneinander dann waren am ende haben
wir beim bäcker haben wir bei kaufman
damit bei mir spaß
jetzt haben wir drei wunderbare kinder
jacqueline saubere allerdings voll auf
die sache war allerdings die mal die
kommentare
egal wer am ende was gemacht aber uns
einfach mal zum zocken verabredet
ja zum zocken verabredet und passiert
den echten fan youtube wir sind ja beim
fernsehen fernsehen wieder nach ganz
oben gekommen
tja die sache war dann allerdings so das
könnte nicht denn jetzt weiter reden ja
so haben uns eigentlich kennengelernt
die sache setzt die einfach dass wir
jetzt videos machen weil in der letzten
zeit was eigentlich so dass das
komplette mit youtube gesehen gar nicht
mal so im vordergrund stand also die
letzten vier fünf monate das ging
eigentlich
ja also dass das im gespräch so dass
zusätzlich zum fordert also man wir
reden oft darüber wie youtube sachen und
sowas einfach nur so das einfach so
wenig in von 280 millionen und einer
sitz in der schule immer direkt neben
dir das einfach so also in deutsch aber
das bildnis einer geschrieben ich bin
unter den top irgendwas oder so in
deutschland ich hab keine ahnung
juli ja auch märz abschließend zu sagen
wir haben uns kennengelernt das war hat
waren ein aufbauender prozess von einer
feindschaft zu raten feindschaft zudem
hat sich zu geben mache ich mal anguckt
dann denkt man dass wir eine harte phase
freundschaft wichtiger wie das kommt
oder so ich lieb dich und dein leben für
oswald auch machen aber das dürfen wir
noch nicht wissen also abschließend kann
man sagen wir haben uns erst ja nicht
unbedingt gehasst aber wie kann und
software aber es ist okay hier gebe es
zu
daraus wird dann hast du warst für mich
so
junge dem man einfach kannte aber nicht
kannte also sowas ja es scheint
eigentlich
kanal also handy kennt doch auch einfach
ein paar leute die mit wo ihr einfach
überhaupt keine übereinstimmenden
freundeskreis obwohl ja nix mehr zu tun
haben und auch nicht unbedingt was mit
zu tun haben müsst oder wollt und das
ist es was einfach und hat sich deswegen
als ich wollte konnte dem fachbegriff
trumpfen aber mir gerade vor gilt ja
revoltiert oder irgend sowas will ich
sagen ich hoffe euch gefällt
ja und jetzt zum abschluss am ortszeit
gedacht dass wir mal den chartverlauf
ein bisschen durchgehen also wir lesen
ist einfach durch das halb menschen ganz
kurz gemacht allerdings ist es echt mal
witzig und ich lese meine stimme
langweilig werde ich mal nicht die 14
paraden räume neben die und haptik
barbie schreibt hier ist mag
hallo mama ich bin mit gc so ich weiß
gar nicht so von kundiger was da los war
dein brot rothschild ein leben an chili
lexware relax und egal was da los
und dann fing das mit den ganzen
freistaat standard pci dss so der keine
hobbys hat als kleine tolle kinder wie
milch mit der relevanten nachrichten mit
dem titel zu nerven
alles zusammen geschrieben opfer
freistunde
ja aber ich war nach hause weil ich beim
händler noch etwas verbessern muss ein
sagt ich gesagt ich bin also ich dachte
nur kurz kommen die mensa melde dich mal
und sagt frau blieb ich muss heftig
kappen dann bekommst du jeweils zwei
euro formulieren
ich kann nicht kommen sollen wollte
kommt was super zusammen 3 uhr die
straße blieb
ok wie heißt die straße noch einfacher
habe ich dennoch gerade geschrieben
alter stärke man sagen wir gleich wo
sein 688 habe wissen bildschirm wenn er
sich über 28 28
von hendrik hahahahaha kann man 2008 mit
den bayern kommt von mir sicher dass mir
der und dann kam von mir soll ich vor
vorträgen zu dir kommen meine sachen das
war die erste nachricht seit dem dass
wir der mensa saßen zwei männer saßen
es war der siebte vierte 2012 schon
wieder
das heißt genau ein jahr am weg eine sms
geschrieben hat auch in der überzeit
geschrieben
die leute trinken schicksal
es gibt dann habe ich von einem dj
autoren in dem macht ihr mal besser noch
mal macht sodass es ist ein tutorial ist
ganz langsam statt sohn andré tier so
dass es wieder game also der ist von dj
antoine dann kann dich dir wenn du das
siehst großer aufwand zu groß abruf
50.000 euro gemacht wir nach vier okay
die erste folge wahrscheinlich nochmal
lang aber er hofft einfach gefallen ich
glaube schon dass man irgendwann endet
und dann controller jetzt meine letzte
gefallen dürft ihr gerne einen
daumenbruch geben und kommentieren aber
was wir das nächste mal reden sollen
steffens in der beschreibung dort wird
die folgen gibt ihm kommen wo wir in
zwei dings spielen immer gegeneinander
antreten mit bestrafen also wenn ihr
sowas sehen wollt dann abonniert den ich
habe ihn heute in sport sein team kaputt
gemacht
das tat mir direkt das tat mit direct
voller ist das weiß ja selber erwiesen
kleines kind kennt ihr das mit ihr und
wenn ihr kleine geschwister da ist mir
auch nicht tun aber bitte sagt das nicht
nehmen lehrer also war das nicht der
fall sei ich habe ihm halt der stadt
nachhaltig genommen und gegen geholt und
dann bist du mit dem knie einfach gegen
sie in der holzbank ging es so und ich
habe wirklich gesehen dass du richtig
voll mit voller wucht dagegen dass mir
so das hat bestimmt dass man da so
steffen das tut mir leid ich dachte so
dass du jetzt wieder kein fußball
spielen kannst oder sonne dann ja egal
wie ich halt alleine weiter und dann war
es halt dann wird die sache dass wir
dass wir halt dann wir sind halt
zurückgegangen nicht so gesagt war ich
kann jetzt bleiben
ok freunde etwas lustig das war
überhaupt nicht da kommt auch ein peter
schütz